once again in atlanta because we've got
new video showing the suspect in this
week's spa killings around
the city of atlanta you can see him
waiting outside one of the spas
before allegedly murdering the first
group of victims
at rallies in atlanta and across the
country activists are demanding action
to address
a spike in crimes against asian
americans they say that this killing
spree is an example of that hate
and police have not yet ruled that out
mark straussman is following this
investigation
new surveillance footage obtained by
atlanta affiliate cbs46
shows suspect robert long waited in his
car for an
hour before he calmly exited the vehicle
and allegedly started the rampage that
killed eight people
six of whom were asian women the
investigation into a possible
hate crime is that still on the table
our investigation is looking at
everything so nothing is off the table
for our investigation
meanwhile the cherokee county captain
who said the suspect was having a bad
day
is off the investigation as the sheriff
said he mourned with the community
i just want to let our community know i
want the world to know
we're better than this
our hearts go out to these people right
now we know the names of just four of
the victims
33 year old delana yon was a wife and
mother of two
other victims include 54 year old paul
michaels
49 year old sha jaitan and 44 year old
daoyo fang police say they have yet to
identify the remaining victims
georgia state representative ben nguyen
says the asian-american community may
resist coming forward about the violent
acts
most immigrant families don't
trust media and law enforcement
and being vocal in a public way
um so i think that is also a
contributing factor
in whether or not we are going to hear
from families
and so that compounds how horrific this
is and really highlights the
vulnerabilities of these victims
state representative nguyen believes
that these murders qualify as a hate
crime
under georgia law because the gunman
targeted women
now i want to talk about something
different which is this
normally by now we'd be hearing a lot
more about the eight victims in this
case
the lies they led what made them special
in this case
police have yet to identify four of the
victims because they're still trying to
notify next of kin
on top of that grieving families often
want and deserve
privacy and as we've been hearing all
week many asian americans
in this country feel especially
vulnerable right now
anthony mark thank you yeah i think it's
really important to underline that
because a lot of people are wondering
why don't we know who they are
i was wondering that yesterday because
normally we've seen several profiles
you've even talked to family members and
i also heard yesterday that
as mark just said some of their next of
kin hasn't even been notified
yeah very very sad situation on so many
levels on so many levels